if you want to check a normal number if
it's prime a small one you just see if
any numbers divide into it you can get
slightly smarter you've only got to
check if primes divide into it and
you've only got to check if prime's up
to the size of the square root of the
number you're checking or not and so
there's a few shortcuts you can make
this number however when you're finding
some look at the size of this thing
right there's no way you
could just go through and check every
conceivable prime factor of this number
to see if it itself is prime in fact
there's a much more clever way of doing
it well i have successfully divided it
by three so i don't know if that it
doesn't technically doesn't count as a i
mean i've taken a prime and i've split
it into three parts albeit not three
equal parts if anyone's curious it's 1
490 pages but i double-side them so it's
about 250 pages of volume okay you want
to find primes previously i showed you
the lucas numbers which i prefer to
fibonacci numbers these are the vastly
superior
luca or lucas numbers they start with
one and
three instead of one one fibonacci and
then they carry on he's like this time
you get four you get seven you get
eleven i need to make sure i get this
correct otherwise it will be very very
embarrassing and what's that going to be
so there's the first one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten so brady
can you give me any number one to ten
inclusive uh what would you like
anything one to nine to ten what do you
want five five okay so we're going to
see if five is prime now a lot of people
at home because the people who watch
number five uh tend to be into
mathematics no five is is prime spoiler
let's say we don't know say i don't know
five's prime or not let's double check
i'm gonna count along to the fifth lucas
number one two three four five i'm gonna
subtract one off that number and if i
subtract one i get ten and then i check
is 10 a multiple of 5 and it is and
because 10 is 2 times 5 10 is a multiple
of 5 i know 5 is a prime number
what
probably
so ok ok give me another number that's
that's not prime just you know six six i
wonder if six is prime let's check six
one two three four five six take one off
seventeen seventeen is not a multiple of
six six is not prime and six is
definitely not prime and so this lucas
test
it will rule out a number that's not
prime so you can comprehensively prove a
number is not prime by using this test
even though you don't know what any of
the factors are
if it does pass then we call it a lucas
pseudo prime it's very likely it's going
to be prime but it's not guaranteed at
this point so this is a very easy test
it's a good first filter to check if a
number is prime or not and you don't
even have to look at its factors so for
a number this big first of all we need
something a little bit more clever and
secondly we want to be sure right so we
want a similar test which guarantees it
definitely is prime if we find it and
that's what we're going to do now right
for the big fellas we need a different
sequence and again it's our friend uh
lucas what a guy what a mathematician uh
and a guy called lima who we never met
because he lived much later after him
and he was uh french and american but
together they came up with this
method which uses the following sequence
you start with four this time
and then after that you square the
previous number and subtract two so four
squared is sixteen sixteen subtract two
is uh fourteen and then we do the same
thing we square 14 we subtract 2 and you
get
194 you then square 194 subtract 2 you
get 37
they get big very quickly so the next
one is a bit of a monster so you go from
37 000 something something something up
here to 1 billion
416 million 317
and then now you can see what's going to
happen we're about to square this guy
they're getting roughly twice as long
each time the next number
hold on is
2 billion this escala it escalates very
quickly and you end up with some massive
numbers in there and so actually it
becomes incredibly
very unwieldy very quickly to do
anything with it we'll fix that problem
in a moment
let's start by proving a number is prime
we're going to use a small n prime on
this sequence to start with i'm going to
use 7 because it is 1 less than 2 cubed
so the way you check a mersenne prime
against this list is you take the power
which for 7 is
3 you subtract 1 off that which is two
and you find what's in the second
position in the list so the second
number is 14 and you see if that is a
multiple of the number you're checking
seven and it is look at that so uh
14 is a multiple of seven so 7 is
definitely prime
let's recap on that very quickly if
you've got 2
to some p prime power there minus 1
and that equals some mystery number if
the p minus one position in this
sequence is a multiple of that number
that number is definitely prime and
there's no ifs or buts or maybes if we
know it is absolutely prime and if it's
not a multiple of that number it's
definitely not prime and so this is a
primality test you can check if
another's prime or not and you never
have to look at its factors this is what
lucas used
he managed to prove
that 2 to the
127 minus 1
is definitely definitely prime by
finding the 126th
term
in this sequence and proving it was a
multiple of that massive number that
come out the other side he also
amazingly managed to prove that 2 to the
67 minus 1 is not prime
but
he never found a single factor for that
number he was able to prove this is not
prime without finding a number that
divides into her i think that was a it
was much later on decades later someone
actually found what the factors were we
knew they were there we used to know
what they were but we knew it wasn't
prime that prime is actually the biggest
prime that was found by hand
all primes after that have been done by
computer so to check this number here
what we would have to do is continue
this sequence
find the 74 million 207
280th position and check if it was a
multiple of this monstrosity
now that actually is going to take a
ridiculous amount of computing power you
can see how big these numbers get
they're going to get ludicrously large
and so actually that is not a good way
to go about it let's make our life easy
because when you're searching through
for this guy here all you care is
whether or not the 74 million to 107 to
180 position is a multiple of it or not
all you really want to know are the
remainders once you've divided by this
number and so as you go along you don't
have to keep track of the entire lucas
lima sequence you just need to keep
track of the remainder
mod this number as you go along so you
can keep simplifying it down each step
of the way and we can do a quick example
if you want to show how that works one
of my absolute favorite medicine primes
is 8191
which is 2 to the 13 subtract
1 and so to check this number we would
have to find the 12th term in the lucas
lemur sequence but we only have to find
it mod 8191 so to start with it's the
same you'd have 4 you'd square that
you'd get 14. you'll square that you'd
get
194. let's get these right then the next
number
should be 37634
but that's bigger than the number we
care about and so actually we need the
remainder of that number once we've
divided through this number in that case
it's only four thousand eight hundred
and seventy that's easier and then we
square that subtract two
get the remainder once we remove
multiples of the number we care about
and you end up with 3953
followed by
5970 and you can see this time these are
staying much more manageable inside okay
then
128 and then the 12th term is
zero
if you square that subtract two you get
a multiple of 8191
and because that zero there's no
remainder we know whatever that massive
ridiculous number should have been in
the sequence it's definitely a multiple
of 8191 therefore that is definitely
prime and we didn't have to check a
single factor of that number okay so
this is what the computer at the
university of missouri did although
obviously it does a slightly more
efficient version of this and there's
some nice things you can do with the way
it handles the binary versions of these
numbers
it's a fancy version of
going along this sequence
finding the result modulo this
ridiculous number but you can do that
just by subtracting
it off until you get a number smaller
than it's that's not so bad
once it got to that position it looked
at the answer there was no remainder and
normally there's a remainder the vast
majority of the times you check a number
of this size spend a month on it the
computer will get to the end and go ah
there's a remainder well it's a computer
it's got no emotions it would just send
back the remainder to the central server
on this occasion it was zero the
computer had no idea what it had done it
sent that off back to the central server
and that was it we had found the biggest
prime number known to humankind so the
problem is this method only works for
mercen primes but actually the problem
is every single time you do it it's a
month of processing work right and so
you think how many i mean this is
millions and millions of months but
obviously we only have to check the way
mercen primes work and there are some
fantastic number five videos on
mercenary primes uh you only got to
worry about prime values up here and so
once if this hadn't been prime if that
had not worked the next one checked
would have been the next prime up after
this and so we're gradually ticking up
through those primes you're right in the
bigger scheme of things there aren't
that many but it still it's a month
every time you want to check one so i
mean definitely everyone download gimp's
the computer program and run it and
maybe you'll be the person who finds the
next one of these matt if they put some
of the world's more high-powered
computers onto the case here for like a
few months would they would they burn
through this like is it silly that we're
just using little small computers in
universities yeah no it's a very good
point if we did have a big high-powered
computer like if google went you know
what guys borrow the server
you know what i reckon if google really
wanted to they could just go and find
the next one if they just for everyone
stop searching for a day we've got
something to do with our computers but
then again i mean what are they going to
achieve they're going to find a bigger
one and then everyone's like oh okay and
start searching for the next one i mean
the point of this is kind of the hunt
and the fact that thousands of people
run the program and any one of those
people could find the next one that for
me is the beauty of the project
it could be it could be anyone sitting
at home running their computer could
make a substantial find like this they
could contribute something to
mathematics and for all of eternity you
would be the human that found that prime
number what would it mean to you if your
computer found the next big one oh my
goodness i would be so excited if i
found the next i would absolutely love
to find it um i mean very small
confession i don't run gimps on my
computer i run a competing prime number
searching outfit called prime grid and
so prime grid searches for other types
of prime so look for like germain primes
and other other ones and so currently
gimps have the top 15 biggest primes
they found them all
prime grid it's a lot less likely you'll
find a prime which is a bit sad for me
but if they do find one in a few
categories they're going to come in at
something crazy big and so i like i mean
i like i play for the underdog so i i
support prime grid because i like the
fact they're doing different types i
mean these gimps guys are just in it for
the glory they're just going for the the
low hanging
easy big ones they're just picking them
off one after the other and getting all
the recognition uh but you know i like
the fact that as we speak at home my
computer is doing maths so i don't have
to
the question everyone has is always what
does it begin and end with ending i
don't find everyone loves the last
number but the top of the last number is
you know it's not going to be an even
number you know it's not going to be a
5. you know it's not going to be a 0.
turns out it's a 1. there it is